a lot of young comics try to immediately
become
george carlin or immediately become uh
bill burr and really have an opinion
that really shocks people
but they don't have the decades of
experience that back it up
what's goodie comics welcome to hot
breath the show where you learn comedy
from the pros
i'm comedian joel byers after 10 years
in this game and over 300
interviews with the top comics in the
industry i'm here to share with you
all the tips i had to learn the hard way
so you don't have to
because that's where you really start to
learn and develop
is when you take the information you've
been learning and actually apply it
so for me personally i was learning a
lot learning a lot and i was like all
right
let me just pick something and start
doing it so i picked one-liners
the one-liner is like kind of the core
of funny it's like how you understand
how to create that surprise
which is what comedy hinges on surprise
so
understanding the mechanics of a
one-liner helped me to then start to
build out my one-liners
into longer bits and then into stories
but it all started with first
figuring out the mechanism of a joke and
i'm not saying
i wasn't doing jokes about global
warming and
corruption and politics like i was doing
jokes about you know living at home
going to college like my dog
like i was doing jokes about basic
topics
just to learn how to make just
things funny a lot of young comics try
to
immediately become george carlin or
immediately become
a bill burr and really have an opinion
that really shocks people
but they don't have the decades of
experience that back it up
they don't have the decades of honing
the screw skill and the craft
of stand up to then be able to execute
those types of topics
starting out start basic learn the
fundamentals learn the rules and then
you can break them
but it all starts with doing
my friends so if there's anything that
i hope you hear this and see this and
remember
it is start doing pick something
you've been learning a lot pick
something and start
executing on it thank you i hope you
found that helpful
this clip you just watched is actually
from our q a we do in our
facebook group where we also do a daily
joke writing contest so if you want to
write more jokes and connect with more
comics
click the link in the description of
this video
and i'll see you there this is a good q
and a y'all we getting healed in her
we getting healed in her